[Music]
foreign
[Music]
exposing Governor Andrew Cuomo's very
clearly defined nipple piercings
pretty open and shut case right
not so fast the real meat of this story
began with Neo Khan shield and confirmed
twig armed beta male Stephen Crowder had
this to stay right there well that might
not be nipple rings
pulled out nipple hair yeah and it has
those little like goose bumps come on
chowder it's so obvious that only a
solid material could make that kind of
impression through cloth
so why would he pretend otherwise
unless he has something to hide
unless brother not only has twig arms
but he also has
a Prince Albert hey this this my wife
hey this this my wife
thanks for watching guys huge
announcement really quick uh I've just
been signed with an MCN recently so
prepare yourselves for truth
whisper out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
would I know
[Music]
[Music]
it's a holiday
[Laughter]
Ahoy everybody and welcome to louder
with Crowder Oh Boy with
Dave
thank you very much I'm very good at
stuff today is National Coming Out day I
didn't know if you know that I'm sure
some of you know that and some of you
might be planning a big day bring cake
uh we're also going to be talking about
uh What uh what to do Madonna and Tulsi
gabbard have in common am I saying that
name right I think so we have leaked
audio of a Birmingham Alabama uh uh Lady
it's pretty racist I don't know if you
guys are it's pretty racist she's down
there in the Birmingham Alabama and
PayPal uh they made an honest mistake to
ruin your life and
uh also Jesus wants you to be a drag
queen apparently uh Jesus who
okay so Jesus yes well the question of
the day if you want to go ahead and
answer that is uh now the Tulsi gathered
uh left the Democratic party who do you
think will leave next go ahead comment
right there it's below me
below me not like coming out day as in
b-e-l-o-w all right now let's introduce
our panel of lovelies Mr Gerald a how
are you today I am doing well no news
for me no news for you no not planning a
big day not a big day you haven't you
don't have a Rip Torn or rip tail no Rip
Torn is a good actor Rip Taylor amount
nope confetti I've already had cake for
my birthday yeah yeah your birthday was
the other day be careful what I say on
this show not because of YouTube no
yourself this show you sell wine so you
have many homosexual clients no that's
not why at all guys I'm gay so not
there's nothing wrong with that they
have a disposable income
and that's true I'll sell to anybody and
outcomes depending on the disease so
what happened uh also we have Joe Lewis
uh he you can't see him but he's he's
not sure where to go I'll make I'll let
him leave poor guy I love Joe Lou Joey
Lou you all right yes he's just he's
still afraid
tokenauen how are you today
we'd be popping though he did works you
good Ahoy to you my friend Ahoy all
right Casey bones how are you today I'm
fine good morning good morning to you
sir Tim the Tool Man Ahoy morning Dave
and you know him you love him I'm gonna
take that from me and give it to him
because he's one of my favorite people
please welcome to the show The One and
Only crawdaddy
thank you David Ahoy how are you sir
fantastic thanks you've been good I've
been good it's been a while since you've
been on the show it has been a while
stomach flu is going around the tribe so
as you know
that's good she got the is it the mouth
or the the Koozies uh the cooties
um both both doing the Palmer horse
so glad I'm at this desk yeah yeah
something's coming out of Steven right
now I want to touch everything one way
or the other to get demons out oh Lord
that isn't it's not fun he's like I
can't hydrate no it's
oh these twins are like little Petri
dishes you know oh yeah blame the kid
they stick the fist in the mouth because
they're teething and they throw that in
your mouth and you have Lou Gehrig's
Disease yeah that's young I don't think
it's that works the young boy's sneaking
out at night no one elsewhere to go
I'm one I gotta be free
it's true though for the first year of
their lives you just you get horribly
sick yes yeah and then you slowly get
used to it that's all it is that's all
it is yeah you don't actually become
well no you just get used to being sick
yeah you never you're not well ever
again degrees of sickness yeah it's a
terrible idea to have kids all right
no it's wonderful no it's the best thing
ever if I mean if you if you like
sleeping or being healthy it's not the
best idea yeah I wouldn't probably sleep
no no that's not an idea do you sleep
well no no
doesn't sleep well before kids that's
true night terrors no the old Sidelines
coach extracurricular activities Dave
rubbing the goods get out there and show
them your meat
it's National Coming Out day oh Jesus
that's not you that was that was
Washington uh yeah they used to be
called the Redskins oh no it was the
Giants they were playing the Washington
no foreskins no yeah they're playing the
Green Bay Packers oh where'd they also
there you go there too say we're getting
ready to pack them well
planet
well today's national coming out Jay and
to celebrate uh well I guess uh Madonna
is gay now I don't know
she's 64 and has six children uh-huh and
it's like she's 94. she died I know yeah
she's uh I'd say she hasn't been uh
sought after since 94.
the wall hit hard yeah the video is a
little strange but it's it's you know
it's nothing you haven't seen around the
office you know at least here
[Music]
dude what are you doing here
if I miss the shot
you gotta kiss me
okay
[Music]
he's a good kisser wow it's almost like
he wanted it yeah it's weird yeah bad
herpes
what's the problem
bad herpes I don't know why Darius would
agree to that yeah yeah he did say Okay
quickly didn't he yeah he was like oh
finally I've been waiting on this moment
did you read my application I've asked
you to play beer pong many times I want
to kiss the partially Asian boy
oh we gotta wear shirts this sucks
and in another coming out story Tulsa
gabbard made a huge announcement this
morning she's officially leaving the
Democratic Party
I can no longer remain in today's
Democratic party it's under the complete
control of an elitist cabal of War
mongers who were driven by cowardly
wokeness who divide Us by racializing
every issue and stoking anti-white
racism who actively work to undermine
our God's freedoms
Constitution who are hostile to people
of faith and spirituality who demonize
the police but protect criminals at the
expense of law-abiding Americans who
believe in open borders who weaponize
the National Security State to go after
their political opponents and above all
who are dragging us ever closer to
nuclear war
now I believe in a government that's of
the People by the people and for the
people
unfortunately today's Democratic party
does not instead it stands for a
government that is of by and for the
powerful Elite
now I'm calling on my fellow Common
Sense independent-minded Democrats join
me in leaving the Democratic party
there's four if you can no longer
stomach the direction that the so-called
woke Democratic party ideologues are
taking our country
and I invite you to join me if you were
a president she'd be Abraham Lincoln
I like I mean I get what you're saying I
like it I think it's 100 yeah
where he's going I don't know I think
she's a lady of the people you know
she's got a Jay Leno shirt and her Val
Kilmer Willow hair okay but she's hot
I thought she also looks like a drunk
bus driver so you know you got that that
works she throws that little gray streak
in for me Dave yeah I like sharing a
little Cuckoo Bird yeah
that's to let you know she's she knows
that's right yeah I'm past my Prime I
like it though I like that she's not
only leaving she's also calling on
fellow Democrats who maybe are more
Centrist like I said I don't know that
there's a ton of them out there but them
to leave the party as well oh I think if
you've lived in any major city and
looked outside you're probably somewhere
in the middle then you would have to
admit that you're wrong and that you've
been wrong and that this that you see is
your responsibility because you voted
wrong and I don't know that people are
willing to do that
I've admitted that I'm wrong a lot but
she checked all the right boxes though I
mean she hit them all hard yeah those
are all areas
all mass and I hope they if the very
least you were talking about this go to
the libertarian party yep I'm totally
fine with you stealing votes from the
Democrats and just going to another
party and saying well we're not going to
vote for these guys at least well I
think if you want to change the platform
of your party to not be lunatics it
makes sense to go yeah we don't really
want to burn down everything and yeah
yeah steal votes we'd like to not be
those and male uh ballots to people on
accident she is pretty libertarian but
they don't pull from the Democrats
though
is if Democrats leave if Democrat voters
and Democrat politicians leave the party
and go to libertarian they're going to
pull Democrat votes to the libertarian
party which I'm fine with because
they're not going to get enough for a
long time to be a contender I'm sorry
it's just it is it is what it is right I
don't even know if they're going to ever
be able to contend but at least they'll
pull votes away from Democrats if if
Democrat voters are leaving with them to
go libertarian because they're like I
can't be a republican because that's
fascism
well yeah
she could go independent too you know
yeah sure yeah that's fine too right
yeah
yeah whatever you want to do yeah
as long as you're not one of them demon
credits anymore yeah just don't vote for
the biology skeleton that's in there now
the gender bread the person yeah the the
whatever is left of the guy whose one
eye doesn't blink
he's a mess I can't he's not even a
person I'm sorry but it's a Million
Dollar Man uh where's the light on a
budget I had a God I'm gonna fight
people named the name's Skittle flakes
all right grab them all right Wrangle
them uh go ahead comment uh what What's
your speculation what do you think she
should do not she but do you think other
people should follow suit what group
should they join maybe the clan
[Laughter]
it could be the black Clan well they're
all so bad all I think all of those are
bad yeah well there's a black Clan they
were in Lansing Michigan they killed at
Malcolm X's dad really yeah they were
the black lansmen wow they weren't black
they just wore black oh yeah well see
that's a plot twist I know
well they they were like we want to do
stuff at night in this white bed sheets
kind of give it away
laughs
geez I don't know they're all stupid
yeah that's right I know some of you are
watching I've seen this show all right
it's a live show speaking of which
Monday through Thursday at 10 A.M
Eastern you can watch us on Rumble
podcast mug Club those are all of the
preferred platforms if you want to go to
any of those or check us out on YouTube
if you want I guess
while we're still on it
and not being paid by them for giving
them a bunch of views so yeah support
YouTube they're great
wonderful people yeah you know what
Chelsea gabbard might be good on there's
a shout out app have you ever heard of
that I have yeah it's a good app I hear
a Gerald Morgan may be getting on there
oh Gerald Morgan should get a shout out
best you can get anybody they can wish
you like happy birthday I could wish you
a happy coming out day you just would
have to pay me for it I'd be like happy
if coming out day Gerald I feel like
you're going to do that anyway I know
I'm going to say you paid a thousand
dollars wow that's weird I'm gonna pay
I'm gonna buy myself one
yeah
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
like nobody's watching I think you
always do that right are we clear did we
are we good did we save the day
yes nay
somebody I don't know hello anybody I
didn't hear I think we missed it oh well
good right away well good got it perfect
okay all right we're back on I didn't
say anything yay with Dave it's my fault
I'll take responsibility because I
didn't use gender
correctly yeah and I want to I don't
want to alienate anybody
no no third rail you just don't know who
you're no 1970s car parts at all none
none all shall be lit let's just move on
yeah we should be good but good to go
yeah good thank you now I appreciate it
sound very confident no he looks like
he's sweating yeah
it looks like it's the last day he's
working here like he's drinking a cup of
gravy worm jacket over here yeah it's
hot real hot and he deserves the guy a
minute ago so yeah you know that's fine
we'll lose all of our no money from
YouTube
[Laughter]
now not that we want to yeah which is
they they should pay him that would be
anyway uh is there some League racist
audio I don't know if you guys have
heard about this yeah it's from Gerald
Morgan's car he's yelling in traffic
also not true
oh sorry I just I'm on fire today
the mayor of Birmingham Alabama uh
resigned actually after audio of a very
very racist remarks uh were leaked to
the media we have a picture oh right
here this is this is the white lady in
question right here and uh it's mayor
Nancy Smith and Deputy Mayor Bubba
Johnson were recorded comparing their
colleagues black son to An ancestry
accessory yes well the ancestry they
also did they were disgusting yeah they
were discussing the ancestry too my
mistake but yes they called they did
compare him to an accessory which is a
little weird uh they were speaking also
in Swedish the whitest language possible
uh Smith also called the boy in apa
which means monkey which as we all know
is very very offensive and racist uh yes
and even though Paul Mooney would tell
you white people look more like monkeys
because they have straight hair and to
put icing on the cake she even had
racist comments about birmingham's
Puerto Rican population these are actual
quotes I see a lot of little short dark
people oh wow I was like I don't know
what village they come from
how they got here and then they also
said 10 fayose which means they're ugly
oh my god well we actually uh yeah I
could fact check on that let me clean
that up not the right so yeah the rest
of the information is below it's
actually oh it I see it was not a white
oh no okay oh I'm sorry it was a Los
Angeles city council president named uh
Nuri Martinez it was in no way a white
lady okay yes my bad okay it was a lady
a latinx
yeah here's the actual audio Yeah
go get the airport from his little
brother that little [ __ ] wanted
a black cat I don't think he's like
all the same thing because why are they
so close
and he's from Massachusetts yeah
yeah no could I ask you during Black
History Month
it's an accessory when we do the MRK
parade
accessories
Puerto Ricans hate parades
the black and brown on this floor and
then there's this this white guy with
the little blackhead who's misbehaved
Este Nino has no he's
a child
they keep bouncing off the elephant
walls on the floor practically tipping
it over there's nothing you can do to
control him
and I'm just like oh my God I'm over
here trying to marry this kid I'm like
you can't do that I said no
wow yeah compared to the kid to a
handbag
essentially saying he was all for show
he's an accessory and crapped on an
entire ethnic group which was fun and
then the worst part of it was that she
called the black boy a monkey yeah this
is actually her photo
yeah go ahead and hit the like button
pretty hot
I mean awful person
I'm not going to say that she's a good
person yeah but I mean we're told every
everything everything that we hear is
that white people are racist against
black people and that's yeah that's why
we chose Birmingham Alabama we're like
all right let's pick the Deep South and
make it look like you know white
Jennifer Garner we'll put that on there
no this is Hispanic people in Los
Angeles well
I have I have news you do
every group can be a little bit racist
[Music]
oh Dave only white people can be racist
I'm sorry let me rephrase that only
white people can be racist
nah it doesn't feel right now
it doesn't feel right no it's not right
yeah it's because this one time I was
getting hit with a crowbar and they said
honky
right you're honking
her comments were almost unintelligible
even with the the transcript there I
mean yeah but she definitely didn't
think she was being recorded
she was doing Spanglish
which happens a lot yeah well especially
in La there's always a little bit of
that yeah and if you want to get your
keys made just send your friend
Sebastian who speaks fluent Spanish and
he'll get them for free they just hook
each other up it's like the Eddie Murphy
sketch where he becomes the white guy
and they just he gets free stuff he's
like what why he's like I'd like to buy
this newspaper he's like just take it
there's nobody around you're white just
take it
Spanish people just do that go white
like me yeah yeah
which I don't I don't blame him I think
it's great to have you know a community
like that free stuff helps so the person
that makes the keys owns the key shop
usually they own the the the truck in
the parking lot
I can't I can't speak with the permits
or maybe they were stealing from Walmart
yeah maybe no they're usually hanging
out outside of the Home Depot okay
that's not even being racist I'm just
serious better what when you get those
free deals just don't ask where it comes
from just take the free yeah yeah yeah
it's free yeah it's totally free it
should be fine before you tip on a buck
such a lazy Tipper I am a great Tipper a
buck I tipped uh a lot I took 50 on a 40
Bill the other day just to see the smile
on the waitress's face
you know why because people are not good
to people read Charles Bukowski I agree
with that poem
[Music]
you know whenever I do that my credit
card company says sends me an email yeah
and a text did you mean to do this yeah
they showed the way just getting dragged
out of her house in front of her kids
yeah
sure in the back of a squad car is this
the lady who took your Amex
so that would be a great ploy to get
somebody fired just way over tip and
then be like no I didn't tip that yeah
yeah they put zeros yeah ah they added
stuff well
I meant I'm I'm in cash and by by
waitress I meant hooker all right well
let's talk about but there are let's
talk well I mean blacks and Mexicans
they do kind of I mean we've all talked
let's talk about Manchester Society for
example in that movie yeah they drop off
uh the cops drop drop off the black guy
in the Mexican neighborhood and you know
amongst the cholos to get his ass kick
let nature take its course indeed and
what they thought was going to happen uh
yeah let's see some stuff about blacks
and Mexicans listen to me oh yeah this
whole [ __ ] thing is like Changing of
the Guard back in the day all these
neighborhoods used to be black and what
are they now Americans exactly it used
to be chicken stands on the corner now
the taco stands in every corner
we don't come together we're gonna be
some extinctions pretty soon
foreign
[Laughter]
are you in good hands
the new 2023 Chrysler Caravan
with the AR-15 fit in five of your
homies
and twist their caps back
all right
gosh oh man
uh yeah that's uh yeah I mean that's
always been though it has it's already
racism that's just just gang Warfare
gang territory but they the what the
black guy was saying was kind of racist
but it was really stereotypical how
about that they used to be chicken
stands on every corner yeah not a taco
stands I feel like the beginning of the
sentence is racist yes he's like I don't
look to diversity oh it's like I I want
to go back to just the chicken well
becoming extinct is is pretty telling
yeah yeah it's not really I don't know
that seems racist in the sense of you
just want the food that benefits you
that's true so if you're white and
you're like I just want the cucumber
sandwich shop no nobody wants it's not
about the food day is that not it no I
would rather go extinct than only have
cucumber sandwiches I know or what about
fish and chips
yes I can deal with that but that'll
kill you too I mean over time well yeah
it's not a bad word Long John Silver's
won't go into those neighborhoods no oh
no there's never a fried food area in a
bad neighborhood yeah we can all attest
to that yes hmm
or a liquor store anyway or check
cashing no no I've never seen one or not
to be found yeah that's nice I pay yeah
I made 400 this week and what do you
give me for it 2 30. great that's
fantastic yes I love cashing my check
with you sir this is just enough to buy
40 in a gun used to be able to find a
good bail bondsman down there but yeah
you don't need them anymore you just go
there and they go you go what's bail and
they go nothing oh and you go all right
system I like it now this is pretty good
I'm gonna go do the crime I just did
again and by the way sir we just want to
let you know you won't be arrested if
you only steal 999 dollars worth of
goods just the more you know tip for you
not to come back and let go again and
that's why
I go to Walgreens don't want to
inconvenience you I just take 900 for
the socks
[Laughter]
you probably could take all the socks at
Walgreens and be like what you gonna do
about it well it would take multiple
trips yeah I mean
well they don't have that many socks
yeah I'd be wearing a lot of Hanes Her
ways
you just keep missing the trash can I
guess I'm still gay yeah
all right
well yes we racism before we're saying
this racism does exist in America and it
exists amongst everybody and I think if
we're all going to come together we have
to admit that and go back to making fun
of each other yes it's better to make
fun of each other than to be racist
towards one another right
of course you grew up in a fairly black
neighborhood yes well you know when I
was growing up it wasn't as I went to
school yeah mostly black kids but uh no
the neighborhood where I grew up is now
entirely black yeah and I think you've
told me some of the highest gang
activity in the country oh east side of
Detroit it wasn't that way then though
yeah in the 90s it was big time too yeah
it's good well no it's not getting
better
only that because fewer people live
there now yeah I guess technically
Dave the house I grew up and sold for
eight thousand dollars that's pretty
good the other two did you buy it no the
other two homes in the street are free
for squatters rights if you pull the
boards off the windows who is coming
with eight grand and like yeah I'm gonna
do this
like how how do you like your new house
I was great I I went in and four pit
bulls ate my girlfriend
I like her anyway because it's because
they ran out of racks yeah what'd you
paint it with blood yeah yeah the blood
of my friends yes
never have to paint it again
oh it's a nice roof what is it oh it's a
there's a tree growing through it ah
yeah great nature it's a wonderful thing
when we were in uh Royal Oak for the
show I took Johnny Boy down you know
west side yeah off of Woodward below
maybe six mile or so he said I saw
Ukraine last night on the news it wasn't
this bad yeah no it had just been bombed
yeah yeah entire halves of buildings
missing just caved in totally because
that's because those were all bombed and
then they didn't fix it they didn't fix
it they were like Ah that's fine nature
will take its course yes we'll just let
this become Urban Farmland yeah that's a
good idea I like Urban Farmers isn't
that great I like when you see him on
the news and they're just holding their
bleeding faces going I don't know why
the gang member stabbed me and took all
my pumpkins
[Laughter]
it's great when you have a high-rise
with a tree growing on the top floor
straight up oh it's amazing just
accumulated muck yeah in a tree the seed
got planted and it grew a major tree
it's like your own little tree fort how
many years did that take to grow that
tree yeah what used to be a high-rise uh
business I'm gonna guess roughly from
the late 60s
if I had to venture a guess
oh good times if you ever wanted to see
a nice Scenic area go there there are
some nice parts of it and by that I mean
there aren't now
speaking of nice things and mistakes
uh PayPal made a big mistake and if you
saw that big mistake you hear me PayPal
big mistake big mistake last week a new
policy released by PayPal said the
payment services
see I do that all the time I already
know the story and then I read this
stuff I I don't need to read it I know
it oh so let me do this again tell it to
us Dave yeah but you didn't drop that
part
last week a new policy released said the
payment service bad Giants
find users twenty five hundred dollars
for expressing misinformation
for if you say you like Trump or if
Gerald is straight
[Laughter]
you're angry out on me I know you're
right it's not your fault I can't read
right
you're just bad with letters it's a it's
a school for children who can't read
good and do other stuff good too really
do anything
I like the way he slated himself like we
could do another take no I know I wish I
did slapped his hand in the desk I read
all the time but then when it comes to a
prompter and I also have Lasik so
there's no excuse and I perform in front
of a live audience all the time yeah for
some reason like well you know what it
is I got I went to the people that did
Lasik for the Detroit Lions that's the
problem so they did it almost good yeah
exactly like they did it just enough to
where I miss every catch
did you want the lineman or did you want
to see wide receiver huh
do you want the quarterback who throws
into the stands so
uh so yeah you don't want to uh Express
misinformation of course and PayPal uh
these uh prohibited activities include
the sending posting or publication of
any messages content or materials that
promote misinformation or present the
risk to user safety or well-being
well-being I love the well-being part
it's like oh let's just use the most
broad terms that we can possibly use
misinformation okay who defines what
misinformation is thanks got it because
everything that we've seen from the
media about misinformation turns out to
be you know wrong but then well-being of
individuals what I I bought an auction
item on eBay for a price that you didn't
like and I said haha great deal and
you're like oh that hurts that's not
good for my well-being yeah of course
like I don't know what snowflake I'm
going to offend on the other side yeah I
bought a I bought a 15 year old George
Foreman grill and it burned my house
down
terrible for you it was six dollars
how about beanie babies right before
they crashed
yeah now I have a whole bunch of well
beanies all over
nice collection of stuffed animals I'm
an idiot that's it I love those people
also you can comment what do you think
this means uh because we don't what do
you think yeah what's something that
what's some misinformation you think
that could be promoted I don't know yeah
how are they monitoring you for that
policy right
you said use venmo and you you tell
people I write I write ridiculous stuff
on Ben yeah I could just pull out my
venomo right now and read like the last
six things I sent someone and five of
them would get us banned yeah because I
never write it seriously that's why it
was fine when they're like the IRS is
gonna look at venue I'm like well that's
sex crimes now
definitely going to prison you know
because
[Laughter]
any compensation you send yeah you put a
note yeah I put a note in and if there's
an emoji that's close enough to resemble
what it was like if there's like then
you'll use it too like two pumpkins
facing each other a sausage and money
you know
which I think everybody does if you
scroll through vendor there's nothing
real on there it's just people like
it's like
that's awesome it's like you paid you
paid your friend 112 dollars for beating
an old lady to death well
yeah yeah that's about right yeah
you are under oath sir yeah I did not
except I did do that yes that was a
comedy it's just joking around you find
this amusing I do
you find people ladies well
hypothetically I mean I don't really but
I think it'd be funny to pay someone for
it
and only pay 112 bucks I mean come on
this comedy I think having a receipt of
killing a woman is funny
oh laughs
right off yeah you're saying I can't
write that off as a business expense
presenting that it's your audience one
of the 87 000 IRS agents potentially
showing up at my door is that what
you're saying yeah so you paid 500 to
your opening act for a taint waxing
that's right
capitalized service
it's a thousand got a deal
uh bring your own candle waxing fire I'm
not even kidding it says these things
so now you're going to take Matt down
with you yeah yeah that's what I'm not
going to say his name he's having a baby
right now yeah yeah it's this week uh
any minute now so you know he's in the
his wife's in the house actually uh
he'll have to read about it because he's
going to be arrested yeah yeah that's
true yeah I was gonna send him a
monetary gift as well to say
congratulations you're having a baby but
I wouldn't say that in it you would say
something else yeah I would be like I
hope you didn't pick a gender you
fascist
but nothing about the race of the baby
no no nothing at all no no no no no we
don't mention that well it's uh
it's not his
I'm sorry
but PayPal saying the whole thing was uh
just an honest mistake no PayPal feeling
the ripple effect from this today it's
stocks taking a significant dip last
week the company expanded its youth
policy to include prohibiting customers
from sending posting or publishing any
messages content or materials that
promote misinformation it included a
twenty five hundred dollar fine for each
violation PayPal's former presidentsize
the move along with company co-founder
Elon Musk today a PayPal spokesman
clarified the move saying PayPal is not
finding people for misinformation and
this language was never intended to be
inserted in our policy we're sorry for
the confusion this has caused okay look
at look at it again okay this language
was never intended to be inserted in our
policy we're sorry for the confusion
it's this cause you said we're gonna
charge you twenty five hundred dollars
for misinformation it's not confusing I
mean it's confusing when misinformation
is but the fine was pretty uh clear yes
yeah yeah and by the way where is the
Bell the radio the language was never
intended to be inserted oh what you
could have said is we never had any
intention to find people for what they
say on our platform when they're paying
people yeah also do you have a legal
right to even do that I don't know I
guess it's a private company they can
probably try and use that why aren't you
dipping into the bank of another private
company well being like that's ours now
well it's kind of like what the banks do
anyway yeah it's overdraft fees and
stuff they just like take your money
yeah maybe just don't spend money you
don't have but hey you know neither way
uh but that that it would have been
clear to say that I think what they are
really saying is we didn't know that you
guys read that stuff like I thought it
was just gonna slip past everybody they
just got caught that's it yeah because a
bunch of people were like 2500 dollars
no and then they told everybody
who's the who's the last person just
access
it's such a gross amount of money that
others found out yeah it's what is this
like a goof that somebody thought would
be funny and it made it through
that bang up PayPal somebody's fired
he'd be like did I pay someone for uh a
used Toyota
I don't recall this transaction that
2500 bucks you took what was it that I
said yeah
I mean I realized that I I sent it to
Matt to eat McGriddles off his chest
so anyway but that really happened so
that's not misinformation no
I guess with PayPal I'll be dead serious
about the things that I do
oh boy anyway it's still gonna get you
do you have PayPal did you
uh uh I do yeah I don't use it much no
no you're like an older generation I'm
not trying to be insulting I'm I didn't
get PayPal until a few years ago and I
was like selling stuff at shows and then
I still claimed everything because I I'm
afraid of uh the Earth yeah I use some
other cash app recently I forget the
name of it uh Zell Square I use l all
the time yeah
Square limo
[Laughter]
I don't know why every female news
anchor has to put on that voice why is
that it is a good point it's like hey do
you want to have sex with El Capone
she's telling the story about PayPal
yeah it's it's nasally and it's I guess
they're trying to be authoritative yeah
hey it's me I'm a lady
got the scoop
and the parts to go with it yes
I've got double D's and two scoops for
you
stupid
honey welcome home hey did you have
afternoon delight oh no no I'll pass
skyrockets in flight
I'm gonna wear my news anchor I'll be
the news anchor you'll be the weather
man I'll throw to you this just in me
in completely unrelated news this is
definitely not representative of a trend
the Colorado Secretary of State's office
accidentally sent 30 000 postcards to
non-citizens encouraging them to
register to vote Democratic Secretary of
State Janet Griswold's office sent 30
000 non-citizens an invitation to go
register to vote
those folks are not eligible to vote
mailers printed in English and Spanish
encourage people to register and
included instructions on how to do that
the mailers also listed the eligibility
requirements things like being a U.S
citizen president of Colorado the
Secretary of State's office blamed the
bad mailing list on a database error the
people who got the mail should not be
able to register to vote if they tried
because they wouldn't have the right
driver's license or social security
number the Secretary of State's office
says it will now send out a second
mailer to the same group of 30 000 who
got the first mailer reiterating that
citizenship requirement
hit the like button helps with our
algorithm and also uh yeah what that one
huh yeah don't use the gun all right
I love that guy saying anything they
shouldn't be able to vote because they
won't most likely have the right form of
identification I'm like right are these
people non-citizens okay I understand
non-citizens can be here legally but or
any portion of these maybe illegal
Colorado and you have an address yeah
why do you go get them why do 30 000 of
them have addresses and the people who
receive the mailership
get out this is that moves probably a
warningly
it's great because the mailer's already
filled out for you
you just have to send them back that's
right
I love how it was like oh it's a
database error and you wonder why we
have questions you make all these
mistakes and we're just supposed to say
like yeah no this is 100 cool
database error
you see what happened is they sent them
intentionally right potentially maybe
well that would be the only way yeah
they got caught realized oopsies yeah
because physically I don't think uh what
a a database put them in the mailbox
well so here's the thing if you're in
the the Secretary of State's office
right and your job is to send out
information to voters you would probably
have a list of
voters yes addresses necessarily need to
have a list of all the people who can't
vote to send mailers to
what are you going to send them a yearly
mailer hey remember you rap scallion you
can't vote that would be odd because
when they came to like renew their
license plate tab you would go who are
you you're just not on the list I think
that's the way to take care of it right
yeah you'd be like this is you know you
don't belong here you don't go to a club
and be like yeah I'm on the list sir I
don't see your name that's usually what
happens instead of like no you're
actually on the not allowed in list so
they don't audit eligibility right right
essentially yes it's fantastic their
name was on a list it must be okay I
wish that worked when I was uh like 18
17 just go to a club and go hey I'm a
hot girl and I'm 21 they're like yeah
coming in yeah we can't say anything
about that please welcome ladies night
you gotta let hot chicks in
I'd be like thank you
June hi I'm Dave
hi I'm also Dave hey there's a lot of
guys here
yeah the bouncer is pretty woke
I have tits
man you don't even need that I'll say
that all the time
every time every time I shower
like look at this look at these sweater
puppies they sound like a game I know
that is fair yeah well I try to work out
and then I stop
these mistakes constantly happen though
as like you're saying in one direction
we should say with the Voting is what
we're discussing well then the mistakes
the mistakes
happen Into You Know This One Direction
the One Direction the mistakes always
happen possibly on purpose CNN and wapo
that's a very derogatory term for
Italians CNN and wapo slandered Nick
salmon that's also a derogatory term for
Arabs
and that was totally a mistake yeah it's
just just a mistake yeah and in 2020
Twitter accidentally suspended The
Babylon B oops our bad we thought you
were real news ah crazy and Jack Dorsey
admitted Twitter should have buried the
hunter Biden story did not oh the laptop
look at that and I'll go ahead and let
you field this one yeah Trayvon Martin
case I don't know if you guys remember
but NBC fired a producer after they
doctored the audio call for the 911 call
because if you remember it's like you
know he's this person he's this person
he's black yeah and they what they cut
out is the 911 operator saying is he
white is he Hispanic is he black and he
just answered the question oh he's black
they just cut that out and that was at
the very beginning of the the whole kind
of
big blow up call that Trim in the fat
yeah yeah yeah no it's called making a
Hispanic guy into a white guy yeah and
also a racist yeah nobody is butt kicked
by a guy defending himself yeah sorry
yeah
9-1-1 I don't even like that guy now no
nobody likes George Zimmerman no nobody
does I'm not saying he's a model citizen
I'm saying in that particular instance
he was defending his life
well
I feel like he I feel like he's kind of
a dick yes and sort of maybe exacerbated
the situation well that could be debated
but it can be debated the phone call he
just answered the question he didn't say
yeah I'm not saying that black dude yeah
I'm not saying that that's what he did
yeah we can all agree that that didn't
happen
I also feel that if your community watch
maybe you're taking it too seriously a
little bit you're supposed to be asleep
next to a pizza
you should wake up to us like did you
hear her screaming and you'd be like oh
man sorry I had my headphones in took an
Ambience started tweeting yeah I'm sorry
I never would watch
what do you think this is this is for
show
you pay me ten dollars an hour do you
have a gun yeah I don't even know why
they let me have it that's weird
another situation where basic Jiu Jitsu
and no one has to die yes right I mean
it was the simplest of things he was
gonna shot a guy yeah they didn't have
to do that yeah if he had just you know
learned to defend himself against the
teenager get a guy off you're sitting on
top of him banging his head in a curb
that didn't have another incident later
yeah yeah
no no I'm not saying you're defending
him at all oh no in any way what the
audience knows like yeah yeah we don't
like George Zimmerman yeah yeah no I'm
not honestly I wouldn't even put that on
you as a joke like I'm not sure I'm not
do not speak I'm sure he sold the gun
too really yeah didn't he do that he
sold it yeah pretty sure he's probably
through PayPal how do you like that
PayPal how's your high horse
as long as it wasn't misinformation yeah
yeah
ah scumbags this next one you'll really
like this I think this was pretty recent
so the January 6th committee admitted to
altering a uh tweet between Mark Meadows
and Jim Jordan
um I'm sorry text thank you very much
we'll cover for both I've got a case of
the Landau I'm sorry I'm contagious
so and this was I think uh Schiff
brought this up representative shift so
the Select Committee created and
provided Schiff a graphic quoting from a
text message uh from a lawmaker to Mark
Meadows and so here's the quote on
January 6 2021 vice president Mike Pence
as president of the Senate should call
out all electoral votes that he believes
are unconstitutional as no electoral
votes at all period right and so that's
what they used as the graphic saying you
know the in the January 6th committee I
mean you know is what I really meant to
say yeah um here's what the original
text reads on January 6 2021 vice
president Mike Pence as President should
call out all the electoral votes that he
believes are unconstitutional as no
electoral votes at all Dash not period
in accordance with guidance from
Founding Father Alexander Hamilton and
judicial precedence no legislative act
wrote Alexander Hamilton in Federalist
number 78 contrary to the Constitution
can be valid the court in Hubbard V low
reinforces truth that an
unconstitutional statute is not a law at
all is a proposition no longer open to
discussion
so there was a lot of context they
inserted a period and also started to
attribute it to Jim Jordan when it was
actually from a lawyer does anybody else
need any further information on the
January 6 committee to understand that
it is absolutely a political circus well
I think it's important when you take
things and edit them yes and make them
say things that they didn't say the
slavery was okay that's what you want to
do for the no yeah
it's how Mark Fuhrman uh got OJ guilty
yes yes yes but here's he threw blood
where there was already blood yes and he
took OJ's own glove and left it at the
scene yeah it's like it's like Mark
there's blood everywhere why did you add
some yeah well
I just felt like they need like adding
quick to chocolate milk
like Norm said he accidentally spilled a
bucket of OJ's
so look a committee spokesperson did
come out and admit and this was their
oops it was an error in the graphic the
period at the end of that sentence was
added inadvertently it wasn't the end of
a sentence how do you accidentally add a
period where one did not exist prior
this was obviously on purpose right so
the generation the following word wasn't
capitalized Yeah well yeah it's an
honest mistake yes and it also was when
you're rewriting it it was forwarded by
Jim Jordan they eliminated half of the
sentence that they were talking about
they didn't provide any of the context
and they tried to show this as evidence
they admitted it as evidence and then
the media ran with it and then they'd
come out and say oops and but here's the
heartfelt apology the select committee
is responsible for and regrets the error
caught
why don't you go ahead and comment would
you believe that they regret the error
no yeah I don't know what it just says
tell them to comment I don't know what
you want him to say
no idea why yeah common uh What uh do
you think that was on purpose
of course you do they're mistakes and
then there are proactive attempts yes to
to mislead I mean it's unbelievable it's
not a mistake oh geez oh no you you
schemed in advance to alter something
for a purpose yeah I I think you put it
in the best way possible too it's you
capitalize something after a period yes
that means you edited it yes it's not
like poorly and it's not like you didn't
have the whole thing yeah this was
evidence turned over you asked for
people's text messages and
Communications between certain
individuals you got it you looked at
this and said this sounds worse if I put
a period here
it's exactly what happened you guys we
know how this works when you're trying
to talk to you know talk about a story
we see it in the news all the time they
just end it wherever it's convenient we
try to give you both sides we try to
give you context we try to give you the
other stories but it's like oh that's so
obvious why is it that people are fooled
by this
I don't know this keeps happening well
because they want to be that's true I
mean if it confirms what you already
believe then fine you'll believe it but
if it goes against it then that's when
you start doing some research and and
Darren I mean this this didn't used to
be quite like this right I mean we
weren't quite so gullible or maybe we
just were and there's so many of these
things that happened we just don't think
about I ask myself that all the time I
wonder if it didn't go on we didn't know
about it we're in such a environment of
communication now but these people
unwittingly create more honesty Donald
Trump's been investigated more than
anybody he's probably the cleanest guy
that's ever held that office it's
unbelievable the scrutiny you think the
founding fathers could have undergone
any of this no no
I mean these guys were weren't perfect
right
but when you're when you're under that
microscope all the time you're gonna
mind your p's and q's aren't you yeah
yeah I mean I mean he did 80 of the time
yeah
the time was pretty hilarious yes it was
made for Good Company yeah
that was the part I liked yes it was the
comedy yeah but don't you just assume
and the economy that was nice too wasn't
that nice look at your portfolio and you
thought my gracious I can retire I can't
until I couldn't right like my goodness
I can't believe that anything could be
worth this much and then I looked the
other day and I was like nothing it's
not it's not worth it anymore yeah I I
called up honestly my stock broker the
other day it's just a gunshot
it's like are you there nothing just a
guy he did one of those Monty pythons
out the window yep
assume nowadays you're always on camera
everything you write is everything yeah
that's why I keep a diary yeah yeah I
won't make venmo comments like well
that's why I do because I know they're
gonna see it that's why I use a
soundboard yeah you didn't say nothing
through technology well I know that
they're going to edit down anything I've
ever said and I'm a comic so the way
that I look at two being a comic or even
somebody in bro if there's a microphone
in front of me and I'm saying something
funny I assure you it's a joke and if
you want to take it as anything else
that's your fault it's my intention not
your interpretation sorry but that's the
reality and that I mean you can either
stick with that or go like oh I'm sorry
I didn't mean to hurt your feelings
because someone told you you should be
upset
it's true though it's so stupid I I we
have to get to a better place than this
if we stay here
I mean look at that that that's a
Committee hearing right maybe nothing
happens with that right so the
ramifications not not that big the only
thing they're trying to do right now is
steer an election in favor of Democrats
by painting Donald Trump as a fascist
and everybody who supports him as
somebody who wants over to the
government right so they're using
projection right yeah exactly that's
important but take it just the next step
further if this works before this easily
duped
democracy goes at some point it just
goes because you'll just be lied to
enough now you won't know it necessarily
you'll be so lied to that you're like no
this is 100 true and we're voting for
this person but democracy is gone you're
just being lied to the entire time and
maybe some people feel like that right
now but that's why shows like this exist
to be like hey guys this is not fun this
is not okay no you can't do this when we
try to do it both ways like we said with
Donald Trump when he said some stuff we
disagreed with we called him out on it I
think Stephen called them out live on it
when we were talking about the guns when
he's like hey can't we just take the
guns first he's like well no that's the
second amendment you can't just take the
guns first no come up with a reason
later yeah right 100 so you have to be
able to do that anyway I'm beating a
dead horse here but still it's important
for us to get to a better place than
this I don't know how to do it yet but
people that subscribe to this show
people that are Mud Club people you are
supporting us doing that so we
appreciate it it seems as though January
6th though is fizzling out don't you
think it's losing all its energy yes I
don't know lost it a while ago but
they're still trying to push that
through and you know they're gonna try
and Lead this into an indictment against
Trump or something to disqualify him
from running for president
um again in 2024 which again
I hope he runs just for the fact that it
would be hilarious what he says and then
he goes I was kidding I'm dropping out
and let you know you know Ron DeSantis
or whoever else is you know kind of the
the front runner with him or right
anything go I just I just want the
comedy back yeah I mean the the way he
even got elected when you think about it
it was just at least when I was talking
to all my friends it was like all right
this is hilarious I hope this keeps
going I really like that he's calling
everybody out and then that is it kept
going it was like yeah all right we
gotta seriously though who do you think
it should be for real for real like you
can't really just have him and then as I
kept narrowing once I got to Jeb Bush
like please clap I was like I think I
think Trump might be the guy
I remember Steven and I and I won't tell
his part of the story but I was telling
him in Michigan when we were up there
like man I uh I just I don't know if I
can vote for it Donald Trump but I can't
vote for Hillary Clinton
I was like it's kind of like I gotta
vote for Donald Trump because at the
time I had seen the documentary on how
Donald Trump and this is true he
basically destroyed the usfl and I was
pissed off at him for that because he's
like oh my gosh like this this league
had an opportunity to form and he came
in and just completely destroyed it with
what he was trying to do yeah and he was
a businessman trying to take something
can compete with the NFL and it
destroyed the league so I didn't like
that about him I didn't know a ton of
other stuff but I was like you can't be
serious he's just running for popularity
like just to get more viewers on The
Apprentice or launch his next show right
I didn't think he was serious like you
did yeah I didn't either and then I was
like well I can't vote for Hillary
because I'm not a Democrat and I hate
Hillary so I'll vote for Donald Trump
was like I just didn't realize we were
going to come down to this
yeah
but he did you didn't realize he'd be
the best friend to Christian no ever I
had no idea
and he doesn't even doesn't even know
why he said okay these people are good
to me I'll be good back to them right I
mean unbelievably conservative in some
areas yeah and that's why they want to
say you know the statement on the bus
grab you by the whatever and you know
that stuff against him well yes
there's no handle I don't know what the
technique would be no you want to go I
don't think you've been grabbing those
what are you fish hooking I mean oh my
goodness what locker room are you in
speaking of which
[Laughter]
Romans uh 12 2 has been given uh an
entirely new meaning by one Progressive
minded church either of you have any
questions from Miss Pentecost
oh thank you yeah maybe she'll let me
borrow it when you're older when you're
allowed to wear makeup we follow a guy
look at the wrist who calls us to not
conform to things of this world and it's
so cool that we serve a God that calls
us to continue to grow and continue to
to change into something new uh and to
not be bound by the ways that the world
confines us sometimes that we're
supposed to live differently
oh boy well yeah wow we uh um I probably
go to Mud Club I go to my club yeah yeah
all right well uh share the show uh and
uh yeah thank you for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it I still use the
word tuning in like it's 1975 because I
don't I don't know words and uh I don't
know what that was but uh piss off
YouTube
foreign
[Music]